[Música]
me imagino que la mayoría de las
personas que están aquí han tenido la
desgracia de ir a una sala de urgencias
tarde en la tarde en la madrugada ya sea
por ustedes o por familiares o amigos no
es así
alguna vez se imaginaron cuántas horas
lleva despierto el residente o el jefe
de la guardia que los va a atender sí y
a mí qué me importa seguro la respuesta
de muchos pues terminando esta plática
ya verán lo mucho que les debe importar
quiero presentarles a los cinco
pacientes que tengo bajo mi cargo hoy el
primero es john tiene 24 años y llego
intoxicado por bebidas alcohólicas el
segundo es daniel tiene 30 años y llegó
por un ataque de asma el tercero es
miguel tiene 28 años y yo con una
insuficiencia cardíaca el cuarto es max
tiene 19 años y llegó con una
apendicitis aguda el quinto es roberto
tiene 35 años y llegó con una
complicación diabética
me quiero presentar guau volver este
escenario tan querido y conocido para mí
soy marco cherem ex alumno de esta
institución estudiante de medicina y
juego voleibol de playa de alto
rendimiento hace un año me entero que
por una situación completamente ajena a
mí iba a tener que pasar un semestre
casi sabático en la universidad
de esta manera alejándome de todos mis
amigos lo cual me pegó emocionalmente
muy fuerte para acabar con esta mala
racha me rompo el ligamento cruzado en
la rodilla en enero terminando de
derribar mis ánimos por completo en vez
de quedarme lamentando me decidí salir
de mi zona de confort y meterme contra
un sistema que lleva establecido de la
misma forma por el último siglo el
sistema de salud de nuestro país
entonces quién soy yo para hablarles de
la importancia del sueño si yo soy el
clásico estudiante que llega en o sin
dormir una noche anterior al examen todo
por estar memorizando el temario los
estudiantes medicina con mis compañeros
y yo desarrollamos esta habilidad tanto
cuando entramos a la carrera una vez que
entramos a la cara
ahora nos vemos obligados a no dormir y
estudiar e incluso ir perfeccionando
hasta el día de nuestra especialidad el
día en donde se nos requiere quedarnos
36 horas despiertos atendiendo pacientes
así que yo quise saber los cambios que
sufre nuestra memoria y nuestro cerebro
al ver cuando como funcionamos de esta
manera los cambios que tenemos de
aprendizaje y de memoria cuando
funcionamos sin un sueño adecuado para
hablar de algo cuando les digo sueño no
hablo de las imágenes que nosotros vemos
al estar dormidos hablo de la actividad
de estar dormido como tal y qué es esto
el sueño es un estado fisiológico que
todos necesitamos para sobrevivir
estudios publicados sugieren que un
adulto necesita entre 7 a 9 horas de
sueño todas las noches
entonces les quiero presentar a louis
louis ya se va a dormir porque son las
12 de la noche y tiene examen de
historia mañana entonces luis luis pasa
de la fase de estar despierto por la
fase 1 la fase 1 es una fase de sueño
muy ligera si nosotros quisiéramos
despertar a louis en esta fase sería muy
fácil para nosotros entonces para
descansar
louis tiene que ir más profundo tiene
que ir a la fase 2 y a la fase 3 son
fases de sueño un poco más lentas en las
cuales louis descanso un poco más pero
no obtiene la recuperación que necesita
entonces louis tiene que ir todavía más
profundo
louis tiene que ir a la fase 4 del sueño
la fase 4 es la responsable para la
recuperación física y psicológica de
louis a partir de esta fase va a poder
seguir con su vida y sentirse recuperado
completamente 90 minutos
después de que luis se durmió vaya a
tener su primer ciclo rem rem en inglés
significa rapid eye movement o en
español movimientos oculares rápidos
esta fase se ha relacionado directamente
con la creación y la consolidación de
memorias de largo plazo entonces es
fundamental para el desempeño académico
y profesional de cualquier persona así
que yo quise basar mi investigación en
esta fase porque nunca se había hecho en
residentes de medicina al hacerlo en vez
de quedarme con la información que
existía decidir beyond borders y crear
mi propia información entonces para
quedar claros la fase rem pasa memorias
de corto plazo a memorias de largo plazo
o sea aprendemos mientras dormimos está
cool no pero qué es lo que pasa atrás va
pasando la noche después del segundo
ciclo de sueño completo nuestro cuerpo
ya no necesita llegar a la fase 4 del
sueño estamos listos para despertar
física y psicológicamente pero
curiosamente en esta segunda mitad de la
noche ciclos rem se van haciendo más
largos cada vez dándonos nuestro cerebro
la posibilidad de aprender más y más
conforme va pasando la noche de esta
manera cuando louis despierta
está listo está listo para hacer su
examen encontrando conexiones entre
fechas y eventos que antes no las tenía
y me imagino que a muchos de los
estudiantes que les están aquí les ha
pasado eso se duermen sin saber que en
realidad lo saben se duermen pensando
que no estudiaron bien y una vez que se
despiertan se despiertan pensando y
dicen guau qué fue si si es común y no
es trampa la respuesta se llama sueño
rem
entonces que nos garantiza que los
residentes o los jefes de la guardia en
los que vamos a poner nuestra vida en
sus manos han cumplido con estos
requerimientos de sueño en realidad nada
nada lo hace estudios publicados por la
american medical association han
encontrado que médicos internos privados
del sueño diagnostican
significativamente menos arritmias
cardíacas que médicos bien descansados
incluso este estudio compara el hecho de
estar bajo la influencia del alcohol con
estar privados de sueño paremos un
segundo imagínense poner su vida en las
manos de un médico borracho o en la vida
o su vida en las manos de un médico bajo
la influencia del alcohol cuando un
error puede ser la diferencia entre la
vida y la muerte nuestro sistema de
salud de ridículo así que yo diseñé mi
experimento junto al doctor héctor romo
para aplicarlo en residentes de medicina
de la ciudad de mexico
y explicaría una prueba de memoria cada
vez lo aplicaría iniciando el turno
antes de su siesta después de su siesta
postguardia y un día después este día
después sería para ver la consolidación
de la memoria de corto plazo la memoria
el largo plazo o sea que tanto
aprendieron a partir de esta prueba
la prueba que ya utilice se llama la
figura del rey la figura del rey
consiste en ponerle a los residentes
esta figura y que la copien sin que la
vean a partir de esto que chequen cada
uno de los elementos de esta figura y
obtener una puntuación que eso es lo
importante o evita cualquier tipo de
sesgo ya que la puntuación está dada
según la precisión y la localización de
cada elemento antes de su siesta les
coloque unos electrodos conectados a un
electroencefalograma para monitorizar su
actividad cerebral de esta manera yo iba
a saber que residente estaba en qué fase
del sueño en qué momento entonces según
los patrones que estoy mostrando en la
pantalla yo podía saber en qué fase del
sueño estaba el residente y si llego al
ciclo rem lo clasificaba como que llego
al ciclo rem y los que no en otro grupo
a partir de eso obtuve mis resultados
pero antes de pasar resultados quiero
demostrarles algo que me pasó y no
sabíamos que nos iba a pasar los ciclos
se acortaron
y su cuerpo intentó obtener todo el
sueño que les había faltado durante 36
horas y ccoo a cortarlo en las 2 horas
de siesta que sabían que iban a terminar
entonces el tiempo entre las etapas se
acortó de esta manera no tenían ni la
recuperación física y psicológica de la
fase 4
nils ni la creación y consolidación de
memorias de la fase rem
de esta manera acortando ocho horas de
sueño en dos horas pero lo más
importante de todo es que ni siquiera se
les daban con nuevas memorias ni
siquiera descansados en realidad sólo
habían perdido dos horas de su vida
estos resultados van mucho más allá de
lo que es nuestro sistema de salud
nosotros podemos entender que al iniciar
el turno y antes de la siesta todos los
residentes obtuvieron puntuaciones
similares pero todo cambia después de la
siesta después de la siesta los
residentes representados en full que son
los residentes que si llegaron a rem
obtuve con una puntuación mucho más alta
en todas las pruebas de memoria visual
que les hicimos
a eso incluyendo le iniciando el turno
al día siguiente comprobando la teoría
de que rem tiene una relación directa
con la creación y consolidación de
memorias o plazo no puede ser que
nuestro sistema de salud nos permita a
nosotros como pacientes ponernos en
manos de alguien que puede cometer un
error mucho más fácil de lo que se
cometería normalmente yo en lo personal
no acepto un grado ni un porcentaje más
de fallo del que pueda tener y menos si
el residente o el jefe de la guardia no
durmió
recuerdan mis cinco pacientes yo creo
que esto debería cambiar aquí les voy a
poner uno de ellos año recuerda cómo se
llama y qué molestias tenía
es daniel tenía un ataque de asma
imagínense ustedes durmieron bien
pudieron reconocer
el segundo quién es y cómo se llama
muy bien algunos no tuvieron el roberto
y tuvo una complicación diabética bueno
y este último tiene pues quién es y qué
complicación tenía
pues no nadie se dio cuenta que este
paciente no estuvo dentro de los cinco
que le mostré imagínense ustedes
durmieron bien pero imagínense estar
despiertos 36 horas y tratar de acordar
caras nombres alergias medicamentos
padecimientos anteriores y miles de
cosas más que debe de saber un jefe de
cirugía esto debería cambiar y está
pasando actualmente confundir pacientes
o incluso confundir miembros entre
derecho e izquierdo dentro de un
paciente es algo que pasa para terminar
quiero enseñarles unas estadísticas que
a mí me impactaron mucho 4.8 por ciento
puede parecer poco pero 4.8 por ciento
de los conductores que están en las
calles actualmente se han quedado
dormidos o han estado que cerca de
quedarse dormidos manejando en el último
mes no estoy hablando en su vida en el
último mes esto trayendo consecuencias
fatales para la mayoría de ellos y si no
es para ellos siendo una amenaza para
nosotros los que manejamos sin estar
privados de sueño
40%
y 40 de los adultos reportan corta
duración de sueño
estos pueden sonar muy normal si duermo
de las 7 ahora duermo menos de las 7
horas que me están recomendando pero no
esto trae problemas graves de salud
consigo trae problemas como diabetes
hipertensión fallas cardíacas e incluso
problemas mentales como lo es la
depresión estos problemas solo por no
saber dormir o por estar metidos atrás
de una pantalla o por ser parte de la
sociedad del cansancio
y el último número 100.000
si 100.000 es el número de vidas que se
pierden al año en eeuu por errores
médicos 100 mil vidas que la mayoría de
ellas son por estar médicos privados de
sueño cometiendo errores 100 mil vidas
que no se perdían de perder y 100.000
familias que sedesa completaron por el
error de alguien más 100 mil vidas que
yo le atribuyó al sistema de salud y a
sus deficiencias 100 mil vidas que no
deberían de existir si tuviéramos un
sistema de salud completamente sin
errores así que la siguiente vez que
vayan a una sala de urgencias
ustedes se podrían imaginar preguntarle
al jefe de la guardia oa la persona que
los esté atendiendo cuántas horas lleva
despierto muchas gracias por su atención